to the affordability crisis now many
mortgage holders are in for more
financial pain the Bank of Canada raised
its key interest rate a quarter
percentage point to 4.75 percent the
highest since April 2001. interest rates
are working to slow inflation but the
Central Bank says they're not high
enough to bring it down to the two
percent Target in April inflation swung
up for the first time in 10 months
adding pressure to hike interest rates
today it's all having a real impact on
the way people approach home buying and
as Mike trolley reports the central bank
and the federal government are facing
criticism that they're out of touch with
Canadians
Canadians working to catch up to
inflation in interest rates once again
saw everything come to a screeching halt
as yet another hike put more distance
between Kate McLaughlin and her dream of
owning a house that's in kind of
infuriating to hear especially with the
cost of like grocery prices and
everything has gone up
um it's like there's just no grasp on
reality the 0.25 bump is equivalent to
180 a month on a million dollar mortgage
and that's on top of the four percent
hike since last year which Economist Jim
Stanford sees as confirmation the Bank
of Canada is fixated on inflation and
only inflation so the fact that
Canadians are experiencing a lot of pain
because of these interest rate hikes
doesn't stop the bank in fact do they
want to see more pain
in Ottawa there was no avoiding the
slings and arrows directed at the
liberal government so Justin
how do you expect people to pay their
bills now
leaving Deputy Prime Minister and
Finance Minister Christian Freeland to
essentially shrug her shoulders while
admitting there's widespread hardship
it's really hard and it is imposing real
pain on a lot of Canadians and Canadian
families
absolutely understand that but do they
because home ownership isn't in the
cards for an increasing number of
Canadians we use Toronto as an example
where the median household income is
eighty five thousand dollars with a 100
000 down payment and fixed rate mortgage
a family can afford a 414 000 home the
average price of a home near downtown is
1.3 million moved to Scarborough it's
1.2 amidst the Farms of Ajax is roughly
the same and even further afield in
Bowmanville is pushing a million and you
can't see the city average just doesn't
cut it anymore you're looking at a mill
apply just for one level of that house
another bonus for McLaughlin with fewer
people able to buy rent just keep going
up people are now in a situation where
they're never gonna be able to
buy but they also can't afford their
rent leaving a for sale sign over the
Canadian dream
microwave Global News Toronto